[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
herzlich Willkommen zu Tatort
Deutschland dem täglichen truecrime
Podcast von Bild mein Name ist Mirko
Kasimir und bei mir ist Tony Hayer hallo
Toni hallo Mirko und hallo ihr da
draußen wir gehen heute wieder weit
zurück in die Vergangenheit mehr als 100
Jahre und erzählen von einem Mord der
wie kaum ein anderer das 20 Jahrhundert
und die Welt wie wir sie heute kennen
geprägt hat es geht um eine
Geheimgesellschaft und
Verschwörungstheorien um sieben Täter
ausgestattet mit Bomben Pistolen und
überlagertem Zyankali es geht um
lynchmops einen Sprung von einer Brücke
einen Chauffeur der den Weg nicht kennt
und eine schicksalhafte Kaffeepause in
einem Straßencafé es geht um einen Mord
mit zwei opfern oder wenn man es anders
betrachtet mit 17 Millionen wir sprechen
über den Mord am
österreichisch-ungarischen Thronfolger
Franz Ferdinand am 28 Juni 1914 in
zarajevo der als Auslöser für den Ersten
Weltkrieg gilt okay noch eine kurze
Vorbemerkung ihr wisst wir sind ein
truecrime Podcast wir sind keine
Historiker und die Frage ob der Erste
Weltkrieg auch ohne dieses Attentat
ausgebrochen wäre die überlassen wir
natürlich den Experten
auch die Ursachen für das Attentat die
Motive der Täter die ganze komplexe
Situation damals auf dem Balkan und in
Europa generell können und wollen wir
nur ganz grob umreißen wir konzentrieren
uns auf den Ablauf des Attentats und das
ist eine wirklich verdammt wilde Story
aber bevor wir euch das Erzählen
brauchen wir doch noch einen kleinen
bisschen backgrounds
[Musik]
beginnen wir mit Franz Ferdinand er wird
1863 in Graz geboren sein Vater ist der
Erzherzog Karl Ludwig von Österreich und
gehört zum Hause Habsburg Lothringen das
ist das Herrschergeschlecht aus dem von
1745 bis 1806 die Kaiser des Heiligen
Römischen Reiches deutsche Nation und
von 1804 bis 1918 die Kaiser Österreich
stammten
sein Onkel ist Franz Josef seines
Zeichens Kaiser von Österreich ganz
große Nummer also der Mann Herrscher
über ein Riesenreich und zudem gehört
neben Österreich Ungarn und Böhmen unter
anderem auch Bosnien Herzegowina auf dem
Balkan Österreich Ungarn hat das Land
1878 besetzt und 1908 annektiert
Franz Josef Sohn Rudolf soll eines Tages
den Thron haben nimmt sich aber das
Leben als er 30 Jahre alt ist die
Thronfolge fällt daraufhin an Franz
Ferdinands Vater Karl Ludwig von
Österreich den jüngeren Bruder des
Kaisers Karl Ludwig aber zieht sich auf
einer Reise nach Palästina ein Infektion
zu als er Wasser aus dem Jordan trinkt
nach seiner Rückkehr nach Wien stirbt er
1896 an den Folgen dieser Infektion
und damit kommt Franz Ferdinand der
Neffe des Kaisers an die Reihe
1896 wird er Thronfolger und damit die
Nummer 2 im Kaiserreich nach dem Kaiser
selbst vermutlich im selben Jahr
verliebt sich der 33-Jährige Erzherzog
auf einem Ball in Prag in Gräfin Sophie
schortec von schotkowa die Familie
gehört zwar zum alten böhmischen Adel
aber das genügt nicht um Sophie zu einer
standesgemäßen Ehefrau für Franz zu
machen die beiden beginnen eine
Beziehung die bis 1899 geheim gehalten
wird bei Hof bemüht man sich unterdessen
den Franz ebenbürtig zu verheiraten z.B
mit der verwitwetten Kronprinzessin
Stefanie von Belgien oder mit Prinzessin
Mathilde von Sachsen aber Franz
Ferdinand setzt sich durch im Jahr 1900
erhält er vom Kaiser die Erlaubnis zu
einer morganatischen Ehe
einer was
ja wird manchmal auch als Trauung zur
linken Hand bezeichnet ehrlicherweise
ist das so etwas wie eine adelsehe
zweiter Klasse da muss die Frau die aus
niederem stand einheiratet auf bestimmte
Dinge verzichten so durfte Sophie zum
Beispiel im Theater nicht mit in der
hofloge sitzen sie durfte bei Paraden
nicht in der Kutsche ihres Mannes
mitfahren und sie musste für sich und
die gemeinsamen Kinder mit Franz
Ferdinand auf die Thronfolge verzichten
ah okay also auf jeden Fall war der
Kaiser alles andere als glücklich über
die Ehe und Sophie wurde wohl auch am
Hof ziemlich mies behandelt gemobbt und
gepostet würde man heute wahrscheinlich
sagen
das ganze besserte sich ab 1909 da
verlieh ihr der Kaiser den Titel einer
Herzogin und erlaubte ihr sich von nun
an mit Hoheit anreden zu lassen ja das
dürfte aber nicht aus reiner Nettigkeit
gemacht haben sondern vor allem um alle
möglichen Komplikationen zu vermeiden
die sich bei offiziellen Anlässen
auftragen bei denen die Frau des
Thronfolgers bisher ausgeschlossen
werden musste
Mirko heißt dann aber auch dass sie von
nun an in seiner Kutsche mitfahren
durfte oder ja oder später in seinem
Auto
da waren sich nichts Gutes an arme
Sophie aber ich greife hier vor Stopp
die Ehe scheint trotz all dieser
Probleme glücklich zu sein die beiden
lieben sich also so wirklich zwischen
1901 und 1904 werden eine Tochter und
zwei Söhne geboren ein vierter Sohn
kommt 1908 tot zur Welt
Franz Ferdinand liebt seine Frau und er
liebt seine Kinder wie sehr das wird
sich an jenem 28 Juni 1914 zeigen an dem
die Kinder zu weisen werden aber erst
müssen wir noch über die schwarze Hand
reden die schwarze Hand ein Geheimbund
mit Sinn für dramatische Namensgebung
gegründet wird die Vereinigung 1911 von
Offizieren und Geheimdienstlern des
Königreichs Serbien sie kämpfen für die
Loslösung ihres Landes von Österreich
und sie wollen Serbien mitteilen von
Bosnien Kroatien und Montenegro Vereinen
dieses groß Serbien soll dann Russland
als Partner haben die Begriffe kennt man
ja bis heute aus der Nachrichten das
sind also ganz ganz alte Konflikte
der serbische Geheimbund nennt sich auch
Vereinigung oder tucht und das Siegel
zeigt eine totenkopf-flagge einer
Handgranate einen Dolch und eine
giftflasche für die schwarze Hand ist
Österreich Ungarn also der Hauptfeind
und zur Gruppe gehören neben Serben auch
ein paar junge Kroaten und Bosnien
Jacken einer von ihnen ist Gavrilo
Princip er ist gerade einmal 19 Jahre
alt und geht auf das Gymnasium als
Zeitungen von einem bevorstehenden
Besuch Franz Ferdinands in Sarajevo
berichten beschließt er den Thronfolger
zu ermorden ein Plan der bei der
schwarzen Hand auf großes Wohlwollen
stößt
zusammen mit zwei Freunden nedelko
cabrinovic ebenfalls 19 und Trifon
grabesch 18 Jahre alt reist er nach
Belgrad wo die schwarze Hand sie für den
Anschlag trainieren und ausrüsten wird
die schwarze Hand ist eine
Geheimgesellschaft aber so richtig
geheim ist sie auch wieder nicht man
weiß Bescheid viele ihre Mitglieder sind
öffentlich bekannt hochrangige serbische
Politiker und Militärs gehören dazu eine
Verschwörung die in höchster Kreise
reicht eine der Führungsfiguren ist zum
Beispiel der Chef des serbischen
Militärgeheimdienstes der
Ministerpräsident und mehrere Minister
sowie Militärs sind zumindest teilweise
in die Attentatspläne eingeweiht
vermutlich weiß auch der Botschafter
Russlands das mit Serbien verbündet ist
Bescheid ende mai 1914 erhalten die drei
jungen Männer vier Pistolen samt
Munition und sechs Bomben aus serbischen
Militärbeständen von ihrem
Führungsoffizier der schwarzen Hand dazu
etwas Geld für die Reisekosten und
Zyankali Fläschchen denn nach dem
Attentat auf Franz Ferdinand sollen sie
sich selbst umbringen die drei
Attentäter Reisen auf abenteuerlichen
Wegen zurück nach Sarajevo durchqueren
Flüsse und verstecken sich in Häusern
bosnischer Serben die ihre Ziele
unterstützen unterwegs schließt sich
ihnen ein vierter Komplize an Danilo
Ilic er ist 23 Jahre alt und Lehrer
Anfang Juni erreichen die vier Sarajevo
und rekrutieren vier weitere junge
Männer zwei Gymnasiasten einen Tischler
und Mohammed Mehmet basic einen
muslimischen Bosnier der als Schreiner
arbeitet am 28 Juni ist es dann soweit
der Thronfolger ist in der Stadt es ist
ein wunderschöner Tag in Sarajevo ein
Sonntag die Sonne scheint tausende
Menschen stehen an der Straße um Franz
Ferdinand und seine Frau Sophie zu sehen
das Paar ist mit dem Zug angereist an
einer Tabakfabrik im Westen von Sarajevo
endet die Zugfahrt das Fürstenpaar
allerlei Würdenträger der Bürgermeister
von zarajevo der Landeschef von
Bosnien-Herzegowina und Sophies
Kammerfrau setzen sich mit einer Kolonne
von sechs Autos in Richtung des
Rathauses in Bewegung damit ihr euch das
vorstellen könnt das sind offene Wagen
also man kennt das wahrscheinlich so aus
aus dem Fernsehen so wie John F Kennedy
damals rumgefahren ist damals sehr sehr
schick und natürlich state of the art
ich sag mal so die Zeiten in denen
wichtige Personen in offenen Wagen durch
die Gegend fahren die sind natürlich
spätestens seit dem Mord dann John F
Kennedy vorbei ja und das bringt uns zur
Frage der Sicherheitsvorkehrungen beim
Besuch von Franz Ferdinand
ich meine es war ja nicht so dass ich
Monarchen und Politiker damals
vollkommen sicher fühlen konnten ganz im
Gegenteil politische Morde waren alles
andere als ungewöhnlich eins der
berühmtesten Beispiele ist sicherlich
der Mord an Elisabeth von Österreich
Ungarn besser bekannt als Sissi durch
einen italienischen Anarchisten im Jahr
1898 im Vorfeld des Besuches von Franz
Ferdinand gibt es sogar eine ganze Reihe
von Warnungen die sind aber eher
unspezifisch und niemand von den
Verantwortlichen nimmt sie zum Anlass
die Sicherheitsvorkehrungen zu
verschärfen das Gegenteil passiert nicht
absichtlich sondern durch eine ganze
Reihe von unglücklichen Umständen durch
Achtlosigkeit und schlechte Planung zur
selben Zeit findet ein großes Manöver
statt Franz Ferdinand der sowas toll
findet hat es selbst vor dem Abstecher
nach Sarajevo besucht
deshalb ist aber kein Militär vor Ort um
den Thronfolger zu schützen dem
polizeischiff stehen gerade einmal 40
Beamte zur Verfügung um die ganze Route
abzusichern und einige Geheimpolizisten
die an der Spitze der Kolonne hätten
mitfahren sollen bleiben bei der
Tabakfabrik zurück weil einfach für Sie
kein Fahrzeug zur Verfügung steht
statt dem Thronfolger bewachen sie die
Schmuckkästen der Herzogin die sechs
Wagen fahren los die Route führt über
den appelkai der heute oberla Colina
heißt entlang des miyaka Flusses in
Richtung Rathaus Franz Ferdinand und
seine Frau sitzen im zweiten Wagen ihnen
gegenüber hat landesschef Oskar pjorek
Platz genommen am Steuer sitzt Chauffeur
Leopold Leuker und neben ihm Franz Graf
Harrach der Besitzer des Wagens die drei
Attentäter haben sich auf der Route
verteilt sie warten inmitten der
Schaulustigen auf ihre Gelegenheit
wo der Konvoi lang fährt und wann er an
welchem Punkt erwartet wird stand in
allen Einzelheiten in der Zeitung gegen
10 Uhr fährt die Kolonne auf dem Kai an
Mohammed Mehmet basic vorbei er steht
flussseitig an der Straße und hat eine
der Bomben bei sich aber er wirft sie
nicht nach eigener späterer Aussage kann
er nicht sicher ausmachen in welchem
Fahrzeug der Thronfolger sitzt und
bleibt darum einfach nur stehen aber nur
etwas weiter wartet schon die Delko
cabrinovic und er hat eine geniale Idee
wie er dasselbe Problem umgehen kann
mhm genial ist jetzt mal so
dahingestellt aber ich würde sagen
simpel trifft es er fragt einfach einen
der wenigen Polizisten an der Strecke in
welchem Wagen denn Franz Ferdinand sitzt
der Polizist gibt ihm bereitwillig
Auskunft als die Kolonne an schabrinovic
vorüberfährt schlägt der an einem
Laternenmast die Zündkapsel der Bombe ab
und schleudert sie in Richtung des
Wagens und dann ja was dann passiert das
ist nicht ganz klar und das obwohl es so
viele Zeugen gibt vielleicht aber auch
weil es so viele Zeugen gibt denn das
wissen wir ja je mehr Menschen etwas
sehen desto mehr unterschiedliche
Geschichten gibt es eine Version lautet
dass die Bombe schlecht gezielt ist dass
sie das zusammengeklappte verdeckt
trifft abprallt und hinter dem Wagen auf
die Straße fällt
in einer anderen Variante rettet der
Chauffeur die Situation er sieht den
Sprengsatz heranfliegen und tritt das
Gaspedal durch und deshalb trifft die
Bombe das Verdeck anstatt im Wagen zu
landen wenn ich aber ehrlich bin die
spektakulärste Version das ist die
dritte nach dieser sah Franz Ferdinand
selbst die Bombe heranfliegen und werte
sie geistesgegenwärtig mit dem Arm ab so
eine Art Bomben Volleyball könnte man
das jetzt bildlich darstellen
naja wie auch immer die Bombe fällt auf
die Straße und detoniert die Explosion
verletzt zwei Menschen in einem
nachfolgenden Wagen und einige Passanten
okay also der Plan ging schief aber
sabrinovic willst zumindest den zweiten
Teil des Planes korrekt ausführen und
sich umbringen er geht auf Nummer Sicher
er schluckt nicht nur das Zyankali
sondern springt dazu auch noch in den
Fluss warum schabrinovic trotzdem
erstmal am Leben bleibt wie viele Pannen
und unfassbare Zufälle es in diesem Fall
noch gibt das erfahrt ihr im zweiten
Teil dieser Geschichte wir freuen uns
wenn er wieder dabei seid euer Mirko und
eure Toni bis morgen